Da sind wir Clixoom, aber auch andere Medien
wie der Berliner Tagesspiegel oder der Österreichische
Kurier einem alten Video aufgesessen.
Dieses Video zeigt zwar wahrscheinlich eine
Explosion in Russland, aber nicht die Atomexplosion
in Njonoksa.
Das hat das Internetportal Corrective herausgefunden.
Es hat unser Video analysiert und die Herkunft
im Jahr 2015 ausgemacht.
Unabhängig davon hat die Explosion stattgefunden
und es gibt Messungen von Radioaktivität
in Norwegen.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, aktiviert die Glocke,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts!
Los geht’s!
Erstmal vielen Dank an Correctiv.org für
die detaillierte und saubere Analyse.
Gut, dass es solche Organisationen gibt.
Und wir wollen es eben transparent machen,
wenn wir etwas gezeigt haben, das so nicht
stattgefunden hat.
Ganz wichtig vorab: An den Recherchen gab
es keine Korrekturen.
Das ist wichtig!
Aber, wir werden ernsthafte Zweifel immer
verfolgen und eben auch veröffentlichen,
damit ihr sicher sein könnt, dass das was
hier berichtet wird auch korrekt ist.
Wie gesagt: Keine Korrekturen an der Recherche,
sondern am Video.
Tatsächlich, das hat Correctiv.org herausbekommen
handelt es sich bei dem Video, das wir gezeigt
haben und das in Artikeln auf der Webseite
des Tagesspiegels oder beim Kurier eingebunden
ist um einen Ausschnitt aus einem alten Video.
Und das stammt aus dem Jahr 2015, ist also
vier Jahre alt.
Es kann also so oder so nicht den Atomunfall
zeigen.
Ich weiß, ein Video sagt mehr als 1000 Bilder,
ein Bild mehr als tausend Worte.
Videos sind unglaublich beeindruckend und
deshalb haben wir dieses Video hier gerne
gezeigt und den Quellenangaben geglaubt.
Im Titel heißt es nämlich (zugegeben etwas
kryptisch): In den Apotheken von Archangelsk
und Sewerodwinsk wurde nach der Explosion
eines Strahltriebwerks Jod gekauft.
Es sollte also der Eindruck erweckt werden,
dass es sich um den aktuellen Atomunfall handeln
würde.
Auch in einem russischen Nachrichtenbeitrag
über den aktuellen Atomunfall hat corrective
das Video entdeckt.
Das Video ist also wirklich alt und hat nichts
mit dem aktuellen Atomunfall zu tun, der vielleicht
viel harmloser oder viel schlimmer ausgesehen
hat.
Wir werden es wahrscheinlich nie erfahren.
Allerdings gibt es zum ersten Mal Messungen
radioaktiver Strahlung, die wahrscheinlich
von diesem Unfall stammt in Norwegen.
Und sie ist schwach.
Damit liegen zum ersten Mal Daten vor, so
dass schon bald ermittelt werden kann, was
da wie und mit welchen Auswirkungen explodiert
ist.
Das hat ja auch jetzt eine Studie über den
Atomunfall in Majak in Russland 2017 gezeigt,
der sogar gänzlich von Russland geleugnet
wird, aber eben nachgewiesener Maßen stattgefunden
hat.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was es mit dem aktuellen
Unfall auf sich hat.
Wie die Forschenden dem Atomunfall 2017 auf
die Spur gekommen sind, das erfahrt ihr in
diesem Video.
Anklicken, anschauen und Clixoom Science & Fiction
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!